I must first apologize for transgressing
on your half an hour and also thank you
very very much for an exceptionally
generous and unmerited introduction and
for a very moving story of Russell
before i start i would also like to
thank the asia society who have worked
really very very hard to make this
possible I'd like also to thank the
huggable Kevorkian Center for their
cooperation Rachel Cooper Lyndon Shubin
from the Asia Society have worked very
very hard and I'd also like to
acknowledge some of my friends from
HarperCollins I can see her tonight
Terry carton my editor Jennifer Swihart
and Danny Mulligan have all worked
extremely hard I've been flattered by
that introduction I should put a bit of
um flesh on the bones I've been watching
Iran as it were from the inside for the
past five years and it's not easy to
watch Iran from the inside as a
foreigner because you soon realize that
the way that you look at things and the
way that Iranians look at things are not
always the same and you have to try
sometimes and put yourself into the into
the shoes of Iranians which is not
difficult because it's very it's there
they really are a complex and
sophisticated people and they're not
always given to being open with their
emotions and open with their thoughts so
sometimes as an observer of Iran you
find yourself trying to half guess and
piecing together little things little
clues that may give you a picture or a
fuller picture of what you believe to be
the reality and then you present that
reality to your Iranian friends and they
say what you haven't got the you haven't
got the thread at all
I've been there for five years almost
and it was five and a half years ago
that I first went to Iran I've been
working as a journalist in Turkey and I
when I went to Iran it was the
high-water mark of something that is now
called the reform movement there was a
president mohammad khatami who had
elicited and provoked extraordinary
enthusiasm and admiration from the
people carta me was regarded as a
visionary and he was greeted as such
when he went abroad and he talked of his
dialogue among civilizations people
believe that that dialogue could not
only be put into operation but that it
might lead to a considerable
understanding and accommodation between
two different worlds the many then
regarded as being in in endless or
antagonism now kata me as a depleted man
a depleted president and the same
foreign envoys that adored him then now
come out of their meetings with him and
say bless him but all he does is bang on
about the dialogue of civilizations
during that time my journalist
colleagues and I have been trying to
make sense of what Iranians think and I
will try and give you my sense of a few
thoughts that Iranians have and a few of
their opinions and I will apologize in
advance for talking in a very general
way without any of the academic
genuflection to class age group and for
lumping Iranians as one which i know i
shouldn't do but for reasons of time and
for reasons of my own general ism i'm
going to do so so how do we find out
what the Iranians think we have few
reliable opinion polls and the Iranians
are rightly famed Ford assembling their
true feelings so inside Iran we are
mixed we are faced with mixed messages
and yet from the outside we hear a nun
interrupted and very unambiguous stream
of opinion from the opponents of the
Islamic Republic from certain members of
la's exile community
and that spokes men and women on TV from
smooth-tongued Iran experts in
Washington and at the important think
tanks and finally from US administration
officials they often refer to the
Iranian people as if their views and
desires can be easily discerned often
they posit a complete and nationwide
disillusionment with the regime they
would pit the Iranian people against
their rulers and alongside the liberal
democratic West the people runs this
theory regret the revolution and they
long for another that will sweep away
the remnants of the clerical regime for
these people America is their example so
what do we know we know that in 1997 and
again in 2001 Iranians turned out in
overwhelming numbers to vote for a
reformist Mohammad Khatami a clerical
while expressing ultimate loyalty to the
Islamic Republic pledged to reform it
and to reconcile Islam with democracy
and we know also that his failure to do
this under mind as he was by a
conservative establishment and also by
his own failures as a politician has led
to great disillusionment this was
reflected in municipal elections two
years ago or more than two years ago in
Wichita a small minority of voters in
the sophisticated mature metropolitan
centers turned out to vote they
boycotted the election even though most
of the Reformers candidates were allowed
to stand and then last year we saw a
similar dip for parliamentary elections
in which the vast majority of reformist
candidates were barred from standing so
we know that the people are not only
less supportive of the electoral process
and they believe in it much less they're
also less supportive of heartening we
know we think we know that the Iranians
possibly pre-eminently among Muslim
people's do not bear out an enormous
animus to the United States the animus
that begs
rest at the beginning rub of the
revolution had subsided to a great
degree from a man who was sent to jail
forgiven giving us this information we
know that seventy four percent of people
living in Tehran favored the
establishment of an official political
dialogue with the United States so what
does this mean does this mean that the
Iranians have shrugged off their
revolutionary principles that they
believe that religion can mix with
politics and that they would welcome a
new generation of leaders leaders who
shave and wear ties and receive
delegations from Procter and Gamble and
touting prescriptions from the World
Bank is it possible that the same
country that just 26 years ago raised
the revolutions and expel the Shah for
selling his country short and for
humiliating his religion in return for
sophisticated military kit and a place
at the top of the third world hierarchy
are now saying we got it all wrong the
same people who fought eight years of
war a war that many considered to be
holy is it possible that they regret and
they wished it had all been different
come back America all is forgiven it's
worthwhile to try and find out what the
Iranians desire because not only is it
an important pointer for Iranian
policymakers but it's also important for
American policymakers because Americans
policy towards Iran as much as it is
predicated on American self-interest is
also justified by what America regards
as the Iranian interest now these
perceptions are very often blandly
narcissistic and they miss the
outstanding color of Iran's political
and social life and that color is the
color of ambivalence I became aware of
this ambivalence when I went to Iran in
1999 and I've been trying to make sense
of it ever since my impression is of
hung over people trying to make it make
sense of the excesses of the previous
night the excess was the revolution and
the war was it ecstatic final hurrah
now there's a headache and empty bottles
the war is largely ignored in the West
partly because Western journalists were
denied access to the front into a lot of
the action and partly because Western
countries are squeamish about
acknowledging the part that they played
in helping sedan but mostly I suspect
because many Westerners do not really
care that for eight years in the 1980s
two countries with confusingly similar
names tried to kill each other and
eradicate each other nowadays in much of
the journalistic reporting that you hear
about Iran you will hear a solitary
dutiful reference to that war but the
effective discounting of that war and
its effects are somewhat akin to
discounting the effects of the First
World War on the interwar Europe in Iraq
the war was an extension of Saddam's
tyranny and I've met Iraqi veterans who
described the elaborate lengths that
they would go in order to desert in Iran
it was very different it was the
culmination the climax of the great
national epic the revolution and when
the war went wrong and the volunteers
further was exploited for political
reasons and the death tolls soared into
the stratosphere and the incompetents
and the cynicism of the commander's
became shockingly apparent then they
felt a doll despair and now there is
ambivalence there is a prickly
defensiveness and unwillingness to
confront the catastrophe that happened
and so although they recognize it as
being politically motivated the veterans
and their generation acquiesce in the
continued official lionizing of those
values and of the wall because it's
really better and more comfortable than
the alternative which is to question
that war and to ask whether in the final
analysis it was really necessary for so
many men to die and when they compared
their former ideological purity with the
official corruption and the cavorting
youngsters that they see about them
the veterans feel a dull despair when I
was researching in the Rose Garden of
the martyrs I spent quite a lot of time
trying to talk to people in that in the
town of isfahan about hossain hi Rosie
hossein hi rosie was a fanatical and
famous commander who inspired many young
men in isfahan to go and to die he was
killed but not before he realized that
those values for which he was fighting
was were being subverted that his men
were being used as cannon fodder and not
before his relations with the High
Command had cooled I'm going to read a
short passage in which I talked with
some of the men who fought under and
revered hossain hey Rosie this is in
isfahan I went to see a veteran called a
meanie he owned a kiosk near one of the
Isfahan big hospitals selling synthetic
fruit juices and tea and plastic cups
after the war amini went into business
and he was unlucky the kiosk was the
dregs of his empire I hung around for an
hour and a half and bought two mango
juices one of which I gave to his
employee later amini phoned me to
apologize for standing me up and to set
another date but his voice told me that
he was more suspicious than sorry you
get used to the suspicion it's partly
inherited Iranian resent now recent past
with its foreign capitulations two
centuries of semi colonization sometimes
seems worse than unambiguous
colonization at least the unambiguously
colonized got railways and sewers and
unambiguous independence as a
consolation many Iranians present the
efforts of foreigners to subject to
subjugate them as a compliment albeit
backhanded proof of what an important
and desirable place Iran is when I'm
feeling sour I replied it on the
contrary Britain was only interested in
Iran because it lay on the route to
India I'm doubly or Tripoli suspect
I speak their language I asked questions
for a living I'm British spy
troublemaker agent I try and smile flag
matically but this isn't easy those who
out to me as an operative of mi6
generally think that they are the first
to hit upon this theory conspiracies are
an immensely enjoyable diversion and
they can be catching the longer I live
in Iran the more i involuntarily
entertain the widespread an insane
theory that the Islamic Revolution was
wrought by the British jealous at having
lost that dominant position in world
affairs to America sometimes I find it
far-fetched that I should have married
my wife for love not strategic interest
that I studied Persian at University for
reasons other than national calculation
that I seek my own advancement and
happiness not a reprise of Britain's
global domination as I walked from my
hotel to meet a meanie my heart was
heavy with the thought of having to
overturn this mistrust coming down the
road that runs parallel to the river I
saw a bus parked by the curb according
to the bunting on the back of the bus it
had come from alvars some 300 kilometres
to the south west it was part of a
convoy that had taken pilgrims from
khuzestan to home a nice to him on the
outskirts of Tehran as I approached I
saw a line of feet protruding from the
lawn at the side of the road I couldn't
see the bodies they belong to they were
obscured by the shadow of the trees as I
got closer I heard a hum coming from the
vicinity of the feet there were 20
sleepers male and they had five days
stubble and long sleeve shirts sticking
out of polyester trousers none was less
than corpulent from their appearance and
the back window I guess that they were
government employees from their age it
was reasonable to assume that they had
fought in the war the hum was there
snoring they had obviously dined
substantially before rolling out their
cane maps by the side of the road one of
them seem to be smacking his chops in
his sleep each one was lying flat on his
back
facing the sky a few had arms out
encroaching on their neighbor they were
having nice dreams of the golden domes
over the Imams body or a cat purring on
the ledge to lie with such abandon in an
exposed place without curling into a
ball or turning this way or that
conveyed an impression of profound
content I mean he was standing where
we'd arranged to meet at the south end
of the olive rd bridge he had a
sportsman's barrel chest and his cheek
was scarred by Crescent of beard he had
penetrating eyes but he was taciturn his
face in his head didn't seem to fit they
could have come from different kits I
later learned that his forehead was a
collage of metal and shrapnel Malik
metal and bone he had about 60 bits of
shrapnel inside him he held strongly on
to my arm onto my hand and said come and
meet the lads there were about ten of
them and they invited me to take off my
shoes and sit with them on a rug they
ordered to water pipes and tea all round
the Riverside had families eating kebabs
that had been cooked on portable grills
and children throwing a ball or playing
badminton the sound of clapping and
singing came from the bridge some young
migrant workers lads from the province
of Lauriston in western iran were having
a party and their voices bounced off the
water amini and his friends were the
depleted shadows of the contented men
that I'd seen by the side of the road
they were superficially similar same age
same great rises and graying socks the
same semi beard but these men had passed
over the cynic yrs and the junkets they
were struggling shopkeepers or
small-time bizarre ease their paunches
were small underneath their jokes there
was a current of shared tragedy
something that I they told me with bland
mistrusting eyes would be incapable of
understanding one of them whose surname
was that mad Kesh had a vivid red beard
which isn't something you see often in
isfahan he was sitting opposite me in a
heap that seemed less substantial than
his broad torso suggested it should be
sorry
Tisha's investigation revealed that he
had no legs they had been they must have
been blown off by a mine he was the
Joker of the group he called me mr. so
it ran with cheetah and the others
sniggered here take this said amini and
handed me the snake of one of the water
pipes he put a glass of tea by my side
mr. Hamid kesha's brought a watermelon
you can have some after your water /
after your pipe we were waiting he told
me for another friend to turn up then
we'd start talking about the war a
conversation started about degenerate
youths I had one of the shop yesterday I
mean he said jabbering into his mobile
to his girlfriend rich kid drove a nice
metallic blue 206 offending everyone
with his crude talk he asked for orange
juice and I said no he said you don't
have orange juice I said thanks be to
God I don't have to sell anything I
don't want to at least I've retained
that much independence how'd you know it
was his girlfriend someone asked it
might have been his wife these kids
don't have wives he replied dryly they
have freedom Simon Kesh addressed me you
have freedom in England don't you he was
smiling unpleasantly I guess what was
going through his mind Europeans will
was lecturing Iran on the importance of
freedom but what did that mean the
freedom to flaunt on Islamic sexual
relations to parade stolen wealth in
front of the mass of the people to drink
alcohol and smoke opium if that was
freedom Iran had a surfeit I smiled
trying to convey the impression that I
perceived the same irony as that mad
Kish the conversation moved on to some
recent street protests they had been
held to commemorate a larger
pro-democracy protest of a few years
before the protests have been attended
by students and other mostly young
people who were demanding more political
freedom the participants had been beaten
up by the police I was passing said one
of a meanies friends and saw everything
you should have seen the cops there were
ten for every kid it wasn't clear whose
side he was on after the demonstration I
saw one cop rip up the seats of a girls
our and beat the [ __ ] out of her why i
asked moral corruption she had a pink
headscarf halfway up her head and she
was made up like a [ __ ] from North
Tehran I also think she may have given
him some lip their smiles were listless
and cynical they were sad I suppose that
a girl from isfahan a conservative
provincial town should dress and make
herself up like a kitten from North
Tehran they were sad as well that her
policeman should beat a teenager with a
baton you could only smile at the
absurdity of a state training and
employing man to enjoy its own citizens
the singing and clapping from the bridge
got louder one of the laws was dancing
sensually in one of the arches arms
above his head his girlish rump pointed
down the river freedom said someone
freedom for them to dance what's it to
us if he dances misters are mad Kish
gave a whole Olaf lettin dance a few
years ago there would have been no
dancing in public on a bridge over the
river in isfahan if a man wiggled his
bottom in public not with a woman just
with himself or male friends he'd have
been arrested he'd have spent a painful
time in a small room at a police station
he'd have got a lecture on his Lahm's
injunctions against a private e if he
went before a judge he'd have been
sentenced to a lashing a bit further
back say twelve years you'd not have
seen much laughing in public women had
to wear black men didn't wear short
sleeves young people with boyfriends or
girlfriends would be severely flogged no
one dared put on western music in their
cars it felt as though the war was still
going on from the snare he was directing
at me it was obvious that Sam had cash
was preparing another assault to preempt
him I blurted out the first thing that
came into my head is that why horsing
her Ozzy went off to fight the Iraqis so
that Iranian policeman can beat up young
women everyone stop smiling we listened
to the clapping and singing I felt angry
and embarrassed after a while one of the
lads got to his feet he said he should
be going
someone else looked at his watch and
said that the man we were waiting for
probably wouldn't turn up one by one
they started to leave Hamid kesh banded
like a chimp several meters to the road
by the curb there was a contraption made
of two motorbikes with a steering wheel
on a platform welded between them he
lept on and roared into the night no one
offered to no one offered me a lift back
to my hotel I mean he told me to phone
him but his tone suggested that he hoped
I would not as I left I reflected that
perhaps they hadn't been waiting for
someone else after all they'd invented
him and his non-appearance in order to
have an excuse not to talk about the war
or was I inventing conspiracies of my
own it may now be clearer why I find it
difficult to answer questions that are
inevitably posed what do Iranians think
of the West do they think the war was a
mistake do they regret the revolution
it's hard to answer these questions
without giving what might seem to be a
very convoluted answer it would involve
my second guessing Iranians trying to
understand whether they mean to deceive
me or to deceive themselves I would need
to distinguish frankness from elision
and to discount the reserve that
Iranians feel when discussing intimate
matters with strangers it's worth
recording that the Iranians are very
good at dissembling their feelings and
presenting them in new and original ways
the poets of old used ellipses and
metaphor to convey complex messages that
could mean diametrically opposing things
depending on the whim of the listener
even now ambiguity is an essential part
of Iranian art about a year ago I sorta
I saw a play in Tehran an adaptation of
Sophocles which centers around the
dispute between Ajax and Agamemnon over
whether or not to continue a very costly
and bloody war against the Trojans the
way that this play was presented
reminded the audience very starkly of
the war that they
experienced and endured against Iraq and
in the production commanders led by the
eponymous hero Ajax opposed the war's
continuation only to be thwarted by a
decision taken at the top level by the
High Command and Ajax is murdered and
when people left that theater there was
not even the need to look at each other
in the eye or to examine their own
conscience they knew what was being
discussed and it wasn't it wasn't an
adaptation of Sophocles it was their own
experience now this sort of illusion is
nothing new in Iran and Iran's and
rulers know it plays like this or a way
of a swaging of pain by turning it into
art and of acknowledging questions
without tackling them directly they are
not a supplement to discussion there a
replacement for the discussion is too
painful and Iranians tend to shy away
from having it by pushing on a
meaningful play you avoid coming into
direct confrontation with the
authorities but at the same time you
give a sense of empowerment to those
people who attend the play how come you
might wonder some plays such players can
be put on at all the answer is that
their audiences are too small and their
message is put across to obliquely for
them to constitute a threat I want to
talk a little bit about a big survey
that was undertaken a few years ago and
the the the the findings started to be
released three years ago under the
auspices of the Minister Ministry of
Culture and Islamic guidance now you may
hear that name and think that they're
probably ill qualified to carry out
impartial surveys but it's worth
recalling that the ministry was at the
forefront of efforts to push forward the
reform movement and to multiply flows of
information and I've been assured by
various people of different political
persuasions but the methodology used for
this survey was sound and the results
are certainly enlightening they show a
society that is ambivalent about the
choices between tradition and modernity
community and individualism theocracy
and secularism that they know one day
they will have to take
so from the survey we learned that over
eighty percent of Iranians carry out
their religious obligations such as the
daily prayers and performing the Ramadan
fast either all the time or almost all
the time ninety-seven percent of
Iranians believe in divine retribution
in short we find a pious and observant
people so why is it that the same people
paint such a dismal picture of public
and private morality almost sixty
percent of Iranians believe that
cheating and trickery are widespread or
dominant across society and sixty four
percent believe that flattery and
fawning are either widespread or
dominant why if the individuals in the
society are so virtuous two fifty
percent of respondents either reject or
question the assertion that the law is
capable of redressing trampled rights
the answer to these contradictions is
that the air the Iranians that were
responding to these questions about 2500
people across the country that these
Iranians are cherry about admitting that
they themselves have become less pious
and more cynical but they feel safe
making a generalization about society at
large so you get some of the best
dancers from questions like do you agree
with the following contention and sixty
percent agree that at the end of the day
the people do not know whether they
should obey the law or use their
contacts to get ahead ostensibly they're
talking about other people in fact
they're holding up a mirror to
themselves the survey is especially
revealing on Iranians and their
aspirations to freedom it shows that
Iranians are perfectly aware that their
democratic privileges such as freedom of
speech and freedom of political
expression have been curtailed
forty-nine percent of respondents think
that it is either hard or impossible to
criticize the state without fear but how
important is improving this situation we
find that its way down the list of
priorities thirty percent believe that
the most important priority is to
preserve the political system
uphold the law twenty-two percent met
set most or by the preservation of
religious values thirty-two percent
believe that combating unemployment and
inflation should have priority aamir
fourteen percent regard the promotion of
freedom of expression and popular
participation in decision-making as the
most important priority Iranians are
emphatically not blind to pull to the
lure of political freedom for the past
100 years they have had experience
albeit imperfect of democratic or semi
democratic institutions but how is it
that are very young populace most of
whom can not recall the heady years the
head a year and a half perhaps that
followed the revolution a time of
anarchic freedom when mullahs and
Marxist were discussing and debating God
on television how can these people how
is it possible for these people to grasp
the ramifications and consequences of
real freedom this is not to invalidate
or poo poo young Iranians who say that
they are desirous of freedom it's just
to suggest that when we talk about
freedom or when they talk about freedom
we don't always have the same thing in
mind and the same understanding of what
that means now there's a freedom deficit
in Iran everyone tells us and most
Iranians would agree but is the state
holy or even mainly responsible for that
deficit I think not for the Islamic
Republic is to an extent reflective of
the Society of a society that itself has
an internal freedom deficit I remember a
long time ago seeing a film by a
documentary that was made about Muslim
Makhmalbaf the Iranian filmmaker this
was before heart Emmy had come to power
and mass malboro said that in his
opinion a lot of the problems that were
experienced in Iran were down to culture
and it took me a while and it was a
while after i came to iran myself that i
understood what he meant by culture it
means the whole gamut of relations that
an individual
as with the people in his immediate
entourage his family his environment
Massmart both is referring to the family
hierarchy to the way that an Iranian
drives his car disposes of his litter to
the degree of autonomy that he allows
his daughter and the type of respect
that he has for his boss is it
discerning of qualities and faults or is
it a knee-jerk reaction to his higher or
more rarely her higher position in the
pecking order I realized the truth of
mass mail box words a year or two ago
when I was talking to a friend a
prominent reformist who said i'm all for
democracy in the public sphere but you
think i'm a democrat at home iranians
twice voted in a president who promised
freedom and civil society and enhanced
rights for women why then is it that
when I spent several weeks in 2003 and
2004 trying to find an Iranian women's
movement I had to give up after meeting
a series of courageous but isolated
individuals who complained not only
about the hostility of men to their
efforts but also of the indifference of
women why is it that a country whose
universities now produced a more female
graduates than male and where there is
no legal bar to women's assumption of
reasonably or very high positions in the
bureaucracy except for a few well
publicized cases are women barely
represented in any important body and
underrepresented across the board in
1999 which is the last day for which I
have figures available women accounted
for ten percent of the workforce this is
the formal workforce which compares
unfavorably with the 1972 figure 13
percent why is it that the very
exceptional women who do reach
middle-ranking bureaucratic positions
speak of a glass ceiling the answer many
Iranians will tell you is that the
Islamic Revolution a mounted above all
to the supplanting of a sophisticated
urban elite by rural folk and their
values
if you think of that next time you go
into a ministry building it will help
you to understand thus loving
slovenliness rudeness and inefficiency
that you will meet with that and it will
help you to understand an extraordinary
transformation to an apogee of
helpfulness kindness and consideration
on the condition that you can
demonstrate an affinity with the person
that you are talking to you're from the
same town you're from the same ethnic
group or better still your distantly
related this explains Iran's lack of
secular Civic values it explains the
difficulty that many revolutionary types
have in coming to terms with the urban
environment that they now increasingly
inhabit how if a man or a woman has been
brought up at home to believe that it is
better that they not converse with
members of the opposite sex who are not
members of their immediate family how is
it that these people can be expected to
strike a constructive and constructive
professional relations with people in
the same office who happen to be of the
opposite sex it's optimistic in such an
environment to expect ambitious women to
thrive I'm not minimizing the changes
that had taken place since the
revolution and those that have become
increasingly apparent since hard to miss
ain't came to power society is more
secular and skepticism of the clerical
class and their ability to run political
affairs has certainly risen another
thing that I shall put in parenthesis
will which I don't have time to talk
about but which is extremely important
is that Iranians have discovered
consumerism the old slogans about caring
for the about caring for the
dispossessed have been largely abandoned
and there is a large consumer thrust and
impulse that is affecting all sections
of society not merely the upper and
middle class but do not assume that when
Iranians say they want democracy they
have in mind the same democracy that you
have in mind
for most Iranians I know and I'm
speculating here I think that for then
democracy means the right to dispose of
unloved and despotic rulers and to
replace them with rulers that they would
like to have in their place but it does
not mean allowing your daughter to dress
as she wants to marry whomever she wants
to choose whatever discipline she'd like
to study at university it emphatically
does not mean giving parliamentarians
the right to pass legislation that
contradicts and contravenes Islam it is
not secular in the way that an American
would understand or a Frenchman although
journalists tend to attach that label
erroneously to anyone in the Middle East
who shares who shaves and wears a tie
then it's possible to argue that there's
a difference in perception between that
idea of democracy and freedom and the
perception that exists among younger
people the children of the revolutionary
generation for them yes it does mean the
right to wear and dress and behave as
they will to consume what they want to
look at and to touch whomever they want
to surf the net with impunity but it is
my impression that neither of these
groups has thought very hard about the
obligations that come with freedom
George Bush talks about the freedom that
the Iranian people want and deserve he
and others picked the Iranians the
Iranian nation against its rulers this
is a simplification for it presupposes
that the Islamic Republic came from
somewhere very far away like Mars it is
true that the Islamic Republic has taken
many of the more objectionable aspects
of Iranian culture and elevated or
glorified them it is true that the
Islamic Republic has taken many of the
more attractive and enlightened aspects
of Iranian culture and either disowned
or banned them it is true that Iranians
are more divorced from their leaders
unless involved in or interested in in
the less involved or interested in their
decisions that a tenant anytime
since the revolution in the Iraq in the
Islamic Republic Iran very often puts
its worst foot forward but it is an
Iranian foot in some ways the problems
and intricacies of the Islamic Republic
of faithful reflections of the society
that it claims to represent in normal
circumstances Iran's transformation may
take a long time but it will happen at
present progress is glacial but look at
that figure for women entering
universities they wouldn't have been
able to do so if the father hadn't said
you can go to university that's a small
but important step and there will be
more of these steps but these are not
normal circumstances for Iran stands
accused of trying to develop nuclear
weapons and many people suspect the Bush
administration of spoiling for a fight
in the case of Iraq us suspicions of
Iraqi WMD programs joined hands they
were brought together with the
vilification of Saddam's regime and his
methods they produced together what most
Americans regarded as an unassailable
justification for going to war both
self-interest and altruism combined I'm
not here to talk about Iran's nuclear
program civilian or military only to
plead that the same linkage not be made
let us not say they're trying to create
they're trying to generate nuclear
weapons and their people are suffering
so that's two good reasons for us to wam
them let's suppose it for a minute that
the Iranians were easily wearable which
they are not and for a minute that the
that the regime faces well-organized
enim internal enemies which it does not
let's suppose that all it takes is a
nudge and the whole edifice will come
tumbling down well you might get new
rulers but you won't get a new ear on
the Iranians in their complex national
identity and their ambivalence will not
go away it is down in the belly of
Iranian culture that new values need to
be engrained grafted onto the old ones
made to fit
and only the Iranian people are
competent to do that thank you very much
thank you very very much that was a
wonderful wonderful talk and we'd like
to open it up now for a brief
question-and-answer period and I would
like to ask again that everyone raise
your hand and we'll bring you a
microphone because we are recording and
so just raise your hands and I'll
recognize you we have someone taking us
yes in the orange how are you able to
shine a light on so many aspects of
Iranian culture and still successfully
live in that culture I I suppose you
have to become in some ways Iranian and
do it in a deceitful and underhand way
I've tried to I try not to um I think
the light that one shines can can be
constructive I don't think one needs to
I don't think one needs to shine a
glaring light I think one can shine an
understanding light and I think that
that may explain why I'm still allowed
into the country and why I'm still I'm
still working there I think it depends
on the level of hostility that you show
and I think if you show that um that you
wish the best for Iran then the
authorities are very often understanding
yes this gentleman here and if if there
is a dichotomy between the popular
feeling toward it's a distinction
between the populace is feeling toward
Americans in general and American
foreign policy is there somewhat of a
dichotomy between the israeli foreign
policy and their behavior toward the
Palestinians
and the general feeling toward the
people of of Israel I don't think I'm
qualified to talk very much about Israel
and the policy towards towards the
Palestinians but i would i would say
that there is this the distinction to be
drawn in Iran between attitudes towards
America and also attitudes towards
American people and I've one of the
things I've been trying to impress on
people I've been speaking to hear during
this trip is that um if you go to Iran
if you go there and travel around you
will meet with extraordinarily
extraordinary hospitality and
extraordinary friendship from people
even those that I'm talking about even
the people that the may the mayim 25
years ago have raised a revolution in
the face of what they regarded to be
American hostility and antagonism so
it's changed yes hi Chris what is your
take on America labels around sponsor of
terrorism what's your take on that and
what's your take on the developments
between Syria and Iran over the last few
days um I haven't I'm afraid being able
to follow events very closely between
Syria and Iran over the over the past
few days so I'm I don't think I should I
should comment very much on that but on
the question of a sponsorship of
terrorism it's well known that Iran has
an integral and organic link with
hizbullah and it's also well known that
they helped set up his bullet with the
Syrians so it depends on whether you as
the Americans and other countries due
regard Syria as regard Hezbollah as a
terrorist organization or whether you
regard it is a legitimate political
movement and that's a nice distinction
that that people make but it's
indisputable that Iran has an has an
organic link with Hezbollah links with
other groups such as Islamic Jihad are
other are murky and it's it's difficult
for me
in Iran to discern those links but yes a
lot of people maintain that Iran not
only set up Islamic Jihad but still
continues to exercise exercise control
over and the Iranians will say they're
only supplying and giving moral support
for what they regard as a legitimate
movement towards Palestinian
self-determination yes sir how can you
wait for the microphone what is next for
Iran after Muhammad ha to me elections
are coming up what are your predictions
um I think that it seems pretty clear
that a non reformist will be maneuvered
into the presidential chair there's a
lot of talk of former President hashemi
rafsanjani whether he comes or whether
or more anonymous conservative comes you
might think that this unification of all
arms of the Iranian government so that
there's no longer this reforms
conservative divided according to the
institution that you're talking about it
will all be in the hands of
conservatives would lead to a reversal
of the modest gains that were made under
ha to me I don't think that that will be
the case although there will be some
incidents and some headline-grabbing
because I think that Iran's leaders are
too canny I think they know that the
Dementor demographic and the enormously
young population cannot be resisted they
have to be accommodated to a certain
extent and so that that accommodation
will continue but I don't expect much
relaxation of political restrictions i
think that the political and the social
for example the boyfriends and the
girlfriends and all that they'll say
well we have to accept that but on the
on the political front i don't think
that there's going to be much progress
yes
do you draw a rather dim picture of the
status of women and their position in
society and I was lucky enough to visit
Iran in two thousand and I met so many
women who I was deeply impressed by
their intelligence and their energy and
their a capability to move within
society and but I was very struck by the
very negative picture that you draw of
their potential within their view of
their society um I don't think your
experience in my comments are
unrecognizable I I to know a lot of a
lot of remarkable women and women who
are who do lead a very independent lives
um I would hazard a guess that the women
that you met were were urban and of
suddenly of a sudden affluence English
speakers perhaps and I think that there
has been progress made certainly if you
come from a more affluent background
there is going to be more chance for you
to move around in society and the
question of going to university is
immensely important because it does even
if you go to university and then you're
married off it that that glimpse of
university life is is very formative
I've what I tried to say in my talk was
too it was to suggest that there is a as
a very slow sort of tectonic movement
going on underneath that will eventually
contribute to the amelioration of this
of this situation but I don't think even
even a lot of even a lot of independent
women still tend to shy away from any
kind of activity that could be
considered political and the joining
together of women's hands and the
establishment of a common front does
carry with it dangers and I don't think
that many women in Iran there is a small
minority that are but I don't think that
many women in Iran are ready to
entertain those attendant dangers so
within their own sphere they will be
independent but they will not
the head above the parapet as it were
you spoke about not being able to find a
women's movement per se I spent some
time in Saudi Arabia where women are
also graduating in larger numbers than
men from college and constitute only six
percent of the workforce but I also
found a disdain for the word
emancipation and you know the women's
movement as it is looked upon in the
West did you find a similar disdain for
the word emancipation because it
correlates to the west you're talking
among women or among among women among
women yes I think um I think I think
some women regard emancipation and a
women's movement are somehow being
antagonistic to traditional ideas and
notions of family life and notions that
they've been that have been instilled in
them the precise routes of that
indifference that I spoke about I don't
know it's very difficult unfortunately
for me to have long uninterruptedly
conversations with women in Iran simply
apart from the people that that you have
also encountered the the minority that
are living in in more in a more
westernized way but um so I can't really
I can't really say what the real root of
that is though it has been repeated to
me on many occasions that that this
indifference indifference exists
I speak to the point no here we go could
you speak to the point as to how the
Iranian people view their country in
relation to the other countries in the
area it's a it's a big question um the
first thing to recall is that Iranians
are emphatically not Arabs so it's
important when you look at for example
the reaction Iranian reaction to the
american invasion of iraq on the ground
it was it was sort of monthly favorable
and people were happy to see Saddam get
his comeuppance and they weren't really
too fast that that Arabs were we may
have been up in arms in other parts of
the world I think the the Iranian
relationship with their Arab neighbors
is probably the most important
relationship and it's definitely the
most the most complex with regard to
Afghanistan will there's a great deal in
common and there's a great deal
culturally and historically in common
but i think that the Arab the the array
the Iran Arab relationship is very
important it's been I would just say
briefly it's part of the ideology of the
Islamic Republic to emphasize and to
strengthen that relationship so it's
possible to to detect among normal
Iranians a kind of reaction against that
I think anti-arab feeling now among many
Iranians particularly those who go to
school and a forced to learn Arabic
where they would probably rather learn
English is is is high uh yes in the back
corner
you are mentioned briefly wwmd program
that iran presently has and of course
you probably remember a president bush's
classification of iran is one part of
the axis of evil some years ago that WMD
program has certainly got to contribute
to a negative view of iran in the eyes
of the US government so what do you
think is likely to happen considering it
obviously there is some ongoing WMD
program there i was referring to the
Iranian nuclear program which many
regard as being a front for WMD program
i think it's a it's a it's a terribly
terribly difficult strategic question
because it involves what you're trying
to do is is is find out what a set of
people who claim to not be doing
something that other people believe they
are doing will do if they achieve the
object that they don't officially want
to achieve and have no interest in
achieving it's really quite complicated
and to work out what the what the end
game is for iran is fantastically
complicated but um i would i would
imagine i mean i've always thought that
the iranians were um would probably be
willing to discuss this whole question
of their nuclear program but that they
would only discuss it just substantively
with the united states and i think um
the US has taken a decision not to have
that discussion with Iran um it may be
the u.s. regret regrets that decision
because they may have left a door they
may have slammed a door that was
possibly inviting them to come in yes
here
are you good you feel qualified to talk
a little bit about the way history is
taught in Iran I mean straight history I
mean how how is Mossadegh viewed today
how is Kermit Roosevelt a a household
name isn't is do the Iranian history
teachers put as much emphasis on the
hospitalization of the Shah New York as
we do I mean how do these stories get
told i think average student they took
it's a very interesting question i think
the answer is that on an official level
a lot of these events are get enormous
coverage every year that the 10-day
period between the chars departure and
jimenez return are commemorated by reams
and reams of newsprint or recalling
these events and and so people relive
them to an extent most adept well the
Islamic Republic didn't doesn't really
like more so there anyway so it wouldn't
um stand up in his defense but they
would say well this is the this is the
first major example that we have of
American treachery and perfidy but so
these these things are the the the the
takeover of the of the American Embassy
looms very large in this in this um sort
of public as a public symbol of
resistance to the outside and you find
um somewhat sad commemorations of this
where people are called out and they
turn up and they dutifully shouts death
to America but you really look in their
eyes and you really you really doubt
that they have have that feeling anymore
it's it's very much I I sense there's a
there's a big element of show what you
get what we would consider do they do
the average students get what we would
consider straight scholarship told you
I'm of intent of some integrity I don't
know what you'd consider straight
scholarship but I I doubt it that's what
I'm 10 I I don't think you're going to
get I mean the the the curriculums have
been changed considerably in order to
incorporate all sorts of things
the first the first thing to remember
about the curriculum is that um for
example Persian literature has been
downgraded to a scandalous extent
because it's um it is ambivalent and
creative on a lot of the subjects that
the Islamic Republic regards as being
utterly unquestionable and and and that
sort of thing um yeah yes I was sinning
run a year and a half ago in two or
three and i found among young people a
very strong concern about dress and it's
a period of relaxation strong yes codes
were not being enforced at the time and
you mentioned that it was in the belly
of iranian culture that the changes
would have to be made over time and i
was interested in that a body had said
that she thought in terms of women's
rights the hijab was not a important
thing with a matter of child custody of
right to marriage of property relations
the right to work equal pay and so on
and that this was not important I've
heard from other iranian women either in
exile or they were in urban areas for
the most thinking that this was more
basic that the dress code was more basic
of the general position of women in a
God for women and I would like your own
interpretation right um I'm only
partially qualified to discuss this
because I'm not a woman and I don't have
to wear this all the time and I um and I
don't know what a water encumbrance it
is or whether it really can just be just
yeah it was rather the premise yeah that
that one must cover oneself yeah I would
I would I would I would hazard the guess
that for Western eyes are relatively
westernized Iranian women the head job
has more important
it serves to distinguish them in a very
very visible way from women in other
parts of the world and it is obviously
an important symbolic it has an
important symbolic resonance for them
but I would suggest that for the
majority of Iranian women everybody is
speaking for them I think that the the
hedge our biz is really a trifle
compared to the institutionalized
inequalities that exist in the legal
system and also the way that they are
implemented by judges and that goes back
to this point of culture i mean the
where the judge has come from they come
from Iranian Society they're not they're
not plucked from from outer space so and
I incidentally have enormous regard for
sure now by do I think she speaks a lot
of sense and I think on this on this
question I would do I would agree with
her the culture of dissimulation that
you refer to ab de seat and ambiguity
perhaps can be understood and I ask in
your opinion in light of the Iranian
history in the last 150 years whereas
you refer to the state of semi
colonialism and later in the Cold War
period where in fact many of the
decisions that affected the country and
the politics were made or were
influenced heavily by outside powers on
the one hand on the other hand
successive dictatorships have caused the
culture it's it's not necessarily
causing effect but it has influenced the
culture to the to the extent that one
cannot for fear of various things one
has not been able to be completely
honest and I and I would bring this
comment to the the guidance ministries
question about whether one is religious
or not I mean I I don't know anybody who
would have the courage to say no I don't
pray at night you know what what what a
reaction would you know I think you're
right
i think if i remember correctly the six
percent replied to that question by
saying aye I never pray and I never fast
and I think I probably know everyone but
I have one yeah one more question if by
some miracle not with any role by
Wolfowitz or Rumsfeld but if somebody by
some miracle we had the possibility of
free party's political parties and a
free election in Iran don't you think
that then it would not be that different
for many other societies where a certain
percentage would be modern secular a
certain percentage would remain
religious and go after a reformist
religious party a certain percentage
would be fundamentalist I mean somehow
from some of your comments I got the
impression that this is going this is a
very different society from others it's
very you know you want never knows what
will happen if there is a free election
um yeah it's a different is a difficult
line to draw because I would not want
you to think that I'm saying that the
Iranians are somehow ill-equipped to
deal with the ramifications of freedom
or of elections but I we probably are in
agreement that elections in themselves
you're not constitute freedom they are
there are a verra manifestation of
freedom and the ability to run elections
and that sort of thing no I to go your
first point about dissimulation I think
I think no one has expressed it in
English better than Richard capucine ski
in his book shah of shahs when he is
Killingly funny about the way that
Iranians standing in a boss you cannot
say it's going to rain tomorrow because
they're afraid that the guy standing
next to them will think that they are
saying there's going to be a revolution
tomorrow and they'll be taken in and I
think um that the Islamic Republic there
is less of that atmosphere of complete
blanket fear there is more there is more
openness about and it is more possible I
think too
sighs than it was before the Revolution
the question about about about elections
and whether or not that would act as a
spur and that these things would
suddenly would would would proliferate
and come forward in response to that
it's it's perfectly possible that that
would be the case but in any case there
would need to be this concurrent
development of a mindset alongside the
institution's the institutions would
mean nothing without the mindset to help
and support them and my ultimate point
the point that I'm really trying to say
is that if that mindset does develop
despite of to prevent it then eventually
whether they like it or not these
institutions will come forward because
there will be an unstoppable momentum
I'm just going to take a couple more
questions so this gentleman here hi I'm
wonder if you could address a scientific
method how it's dealt with in Iran an
official level is there any analog like
between evolution and creation science
which is is out yeah if you could just
address in it um I'm afraid I can't
reply ah I can't answer that question
i'm not i haven't some i haven't done
any any work and I'm very embarrassed
i'm afraid i don't know i mean the
evolution story is very important at the
the the biblical story of creation is
very important in the mosque I don't
know the extent to which it's um it's
emphasized in schools I just don't know
yes back here I'm sorry I came so late
and I missed your presentation but
before coming I looked up your name in
connection with dr. kepta car the vice
president of iran or environment mm-hmm
and i didn't see any connect
it might have been that Google didn't
pick it up but could you comment on dr.
epic are and who is as people here may
know a scientist and a woman vice
president of iran who speaks English
without an accent and who was are you
nuts right sorry about that very good
now without she speaks with an American
accent I believe and was the
spokesperson for the hostage takers and
has a book out could you comment on her
visa be the role of women and science in
the government and society of Iran thank
you um yes I've never met her and I've
never interviewed her but I know people
who have I don't know much about her
background as a scientist I know that
she's trying to she's trying to reduce
pollution and that she hasn't been very
successful but I don't think that's
necessarily down to her own failings as
a politician the people that I know who
have met her are as a very impressed by
as you say her flawless English and also
her book is I know other people have
read the book and like the book but she
was the she was the sort of them the
symbol of of a woman who was part of the
Islamic Republic who could achieve high
office and I think to the extent that
she's used that high office and and
exploited the opportunities that it
presented I think she's probably
considered to have failed because she
has neither raised the awareness of the
environment to anything like the extent
that it needs to be needs to be raised
nor has she spoken out very very
strongly or it's all forthrightly about
other areas of the laws that pertain to
women that could be modified and changed
to their advantage so I'm going to take
one more question yes
as we are on the confines the Asia side
tonight I would wonder if you could
comment on the burgeoning relationship
between Iran and China specifically
energy sector and beyond yeah it's we
journalists tend to look on this as a as
a canny geostrategic strategical move
made by the Iranians the Iranians will
supply Iran with some of the energy it
needs in order to become a dominant
power in return China will use its
influence at the Security Council in
order to prevent sanctions or or or
other measures being taken against being
taken against Iran it's a very
interesting relationship some of the
Iranian conservatives regard China as a
kind of model they would like to have
China as a model for development where
you have you can introduce all sorts of
innovations from the private sector and
economic innovations while at the same
time restricting the development of
political freedoms we'll have to see
whether all that gas and all that oil
actually gets delivered I mean the deal
is is only a framework agreement
although it grabbed the headlines across
the world it's only a framework
agreement and we'll have to see whether
that actually translates into this and
if it does then we'll have an important
relationship that could have a very big
effect on not only on Iran's future but
also China's I'd like to thank you all
and I'd like to thank Christopher de
ballet for a wonderful and insightful